d'accord, écoutez, c'est ainsi que nous accordons la priorité à la santé
et à la sécurité
en veillant à ce qu'il y ait un mandat de vaccination
qui atteigne tout le monde
universellement dans le secteur privé beaucoup
de gens du secteur privé m'ont dit
qu'ils croient en la vaccination mais ils ne savent pas trop comment ils peuvent le faire eux-mêmes bien nous allons le faire
vous savez que cela ne
vous protège pas seulement en tant qu'individu, cela
aide également à protéger vos amis les
membres de votre famille vos collègues en
même temps vous devriez obliger les gens
à faire quelque chose qu'ils ne veulent pas faire ce n'est pas
grossier ou inhabituel ce n'est pas les droits de l'homme
vous devez protéger la plupart des
gens
et cela a été prouvé par les scientifiques
jusqu'à présent sur la recherche que je comprends
que
cela nous protège le plus si tout le monde
a le vaccin donc
je le soutiens
vous